-The Oscars were last night,
and here with a recap is one
of our writers, Amber Ruffin,
in a segment we call
"Amber Says What."
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You guys! What?!
The Oscars were crazy!
Okay, first of all,
everyone looked too beautiful.
Danai Gurira's dress
was like, what?!
Then Kacey Musgraves' dress
And then Regina King's leg
was like, what?
[ Laughter ]
Then people were like, "You have
to see Billy Porter's tuxedo."
And I was like, "What?"
Then I saw the whole thing!
It was like, what?!
Aaah! Aaah!
Then I saw Paul Rudd
and was like, "What...
is Paul Rudd's son doing here?"
Then someone was like,
"That's Paul Rudd."
And I was like, "Which one
of his parents is black?
Because it has not cracked."
Then...
Then the night started,
and everyone was like,
"Who is gonna win?"
And every black person I know
was like,
"Who cares, as long
as it's not 'Green Book.'"
[ Laughter ]
-Whoo!
-Then -- Whoo right back at ya.
Then right off the bat,
"Black Panther" won two Oscars!
And I was like, "What, what?!"
Yay!
[ Cheers and applause ]
And then Bradley Cooper
and Lady Gaga sang a duet.
And I was like ♪ Whaaaaaat ♪
[ Laughter, applause ]
Then "Green Book" --
Yeah, you can clap extra
'cause it was so great.
Then "Green Book"
won Best Screenplay.
But the real star was
Samuel L. Jackson's face.
'Cause he opened up
that envelope,
and his face was like, "What?"
[ Laughter ]
Look at him!
[ Applause ]
I haven't seen his face
look like that
since there were a bunch
of snakes on his plane.
Now, if you think
that face was rude,
let me give you
a little backstory.
A million years ago,
Samuel L. Jackson
was in a Spike Lee movie
called "Do the Right Thing,"
which is one of the best movies
of all time
and wasn't even nominated.
The winner that year
was "Driving Miss Daisy."
Fast-forward to today,
when another Spike Lee movie
lost to "Driving Miss Daisy 2."
This time, the white one drives!
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Then Alfonso Cuarón won
Best Director for "Roma"!
And I was like, "What?!"
Ha-ha-ha-ha-ha!
Then I read that it was
the fifth time in six years
a Mexican director
won Best Director.
And I was like, "Qué?"
Shoot.
Five Oscars.
You better put a door in that
border wall for filmmakers.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Trying to see some movies.
Aah!
Then Olivia Colman
won Best Actress,
and she was like
[British accent] "What?
I thought Glenn Close
was going to win."
[ Normal voice ] And Glenn Close
was like, "Bitch, so did I!"
[ Laughter, applause ]
"Why do you think I came
dressed as an Oscar?"
Whoo!
[ Audience cheers ]
Yeah! [ Laughs ]
That was so call and response.
Whoo!
-Whoo!
-Y'all stupid.
And I was rooting
for Glenn Close,
because we feel the same way
about Billy Porter's outfit.
Check out what she did when
she saw it on the red carpet.
-The children are serving us
with their looks
on the red carpet.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Now, I don't know what happened
to her in that moment,
but I think it was better
than winning an Oscar.
Then "Green Book"
won Best Picture.
And I was like, "What?
Oh, no!"
And I yelled it so loud,
I woke up my husband,
and he was like,
"What, did someone break in?
What's wrong?"
And I was like, "Worse!"
'Green Book' won Best Picture."
And that made me really sad.
So I thought about my favorite
thing that happened this week.
No.
[ Laughter ]
Not that one.
My second favorite thing
that happened this week.
Yay!
[ Cheers and applause ]
This has been
"Amber Says ♪ Whaaaat ♪"
-Give it up for Amber Ruffin,
everybody.